Steve Lyons and Steve as we get set to
get things going it's the pitching that
has to be considered one of the strong
points on this ballclub
pitching is going to be important for
these guys no question about it they're
only going to go as far as this group
right here is going to take them and to
me it looks like a staff that's capable
of getting the job done more from the
guys as this one goes along but first
let's get a look at the starting lineup
for the visiting Boston Red Sox as John
Farrell's guys will line up like this
he'll go to work against the most
valuable player from the 2008 world
series the change-up specialist
left-hander Cole Hamels
now we'll look at the way the phillies
will line up behind him
mookie betts step to the plate now as
we're ready to get this one under way
looky
this ball hit in the air down the right
side and out of play 0 & 1
here comes in the old one scent on the
ground is second for roughly
so the base is empty here with one way
and that'll bring up the former MVP
second baseman dustin pedroia here's the
first offering and this is lined into
left field for their first hit of the
ballgame
well if these guys are going to do with
anything this season he's gonna need to
be a big part of that offense and he
comes through big time right here with a
base hit in his very first step back
David Ortiz will get his first shot now
with the runner at first following the
one-out single
first pitch coming grounded foul toward
the third-base dugout
he set now the pitch this is swung on
and lifted down the left field line but
it'll get back into the crowd as he
jumps ahead of him now oh and to
now the fit
and Ortiz hits one
David Ortiz a two run home run and that
gives the Red Sox a two to nothing lead
and you know after a month down in
spring training near the end you start
to get a little anxious waiting for the
season to get going I guarantee it he's
been looking forward to this at-bat for
about a month now and he makes a wait
worthwhile mounting porn here's Hanley
Ramirez and
hit hard down the left-field line but
this is going to get foul
now here it comes hammer the other way
to deep right field and that one is out
of here plant it into the right field
bleachers
it's a solo shot for Hanley Ramirez as
the Red Sox have moved out three to
nothing
and early on here he's having real
trouble locating his pitches I mean this
is another pitch that's biting off way
too much of the plate they roughed them
up for two home runs already we're not
out of the first yet honey so the bases
are empty with one man gone and standing
in now the versatile Pablo Sandoval
now here's the first pitch swinging a
shot toward right-center and this will
find the gap for Sandoval should be
extra bases the throw into second and
he's going to make it there barely as
he's into second base with a double shot
him six boy that's now three extra base
hits he's calmed up here in the first
inning and a lot of times that doesn't
bode all that well for him sticking
around late into a ball game so he's
gonna need to turn things around right
now or he might be looking at a real
short outing
here's Shane Victorino now as Hamels
will jump ahead of him its own one fell
for Sandoval he records his first
doubled of the year here on opening day
hitch home to Victorino hid well down
the left field line but back into the
crowd foul
he set now the pitch and now this is
swung on and lifted in the air to left
center
revere will lanes to his left as he
cracks this one down in left center for
the second out of the inning batting
seventh shortstop Xander Bogaerts
Xander Bogaerts will stand in here for
the first time looking to pick up that
runner from second with two away here
first pitch on the way he swings and
pops it high in the air out towards
shallow right
and Utley will make the catch to retire
the side so two home runs in the inning
lead to three runs on the scoreboard on
now to the bottom of any number one the
Red Sox on top three to nothing
you